does Ellie believe Joel's big lie was
Ellie prepared to Die For the Cure the
last episode of The Last of Us season 1
is as heartbreaking and divisive as the
ending of the game is based on warning
spoilers ahead thus enigmatic as Joel
Miller is the audience gets to know a
lot about him in The Last of Us series
premiere Ellie on the other hand remains
a mystery for most of season one vital
blanks about her don't get filled in
until the final three episodes perhaps
the most significant of these open
questions is why is Ellie immune to
cordyceps viewers are also left
wondering about her parentage as well as
her relationship with Marlene
or something
and look like your mom
do not
the finale opens with a harrowing
pre-title sequence in which a pregnant
woman is running for her life through
the woods before taking shelter in an
abandoned building this is Anna who is
in the final stages of labor when an
infected breaches the door and attacks
her just as she's delivering her baby
whom she names Ellie she manages to kill
her attacker but not before she's bitten
in the thigh to save her child from
exposure she cuts the umbilical cord
with the same knife with which she
despise the infected Runner surely
thereafter Marlene arrives Anna assures
her that she was bitten after the cord
was cut but Marlene is skeptical and we
know it's a lie it's implied that the
exact moment of her birth rendered Ellie
immune Marlene promises to care for the
baby before killing her friend before
she turns presumably she waits the Sea
of infant Ali is showing symptoms before
eventually stashing her with Federer
where she can keep her safe and keep
tabs on her when Ellie proves to be
resistant to cordyceps Marlene and the
fireflies Take A Renewed interest in
this miracle child
initially Joel agrees to transport Sally
out west to a makeshift Firefly Hospital
in exchange for some sort of payment as
a bonus it's his best move for getting
out of the busting QC alive and his best
hope of finding Tommy versus he and his
Plucky cargo approached her final
destination it's painfully obvious that
Joel no longer cares about his Bounty
from Ellie's unusually flat effect we
can deduce that is only Dawning on her
and Joel what reaching their goal might
mean not to mention that she's clearly
been traumatized from the horrific
events of episode 8. he floats the idea
of foregoing their mission suggesting
they could instead return to Tommy's
settlement and try to live as normal a
life as possible and he thanks him for
protecting her and safety to follow him
anywhere but insists they keep looking
for the hospital Ali says that after all
she's done she has to see their journey
through to its end he can't be for
nothing
she tells Joe that there's no going
halfway with their mission which could
mean that she has realized what might
happen to her if they succeed what's
Weighing on Ellie's conscience is
twofold to survive she's killed people
and people have died on her behalf some
of those people were Innocents and loved
ones Ali can't justify a morally
compromised actions if they were only to
buy herself some more time even if that
time is more meaningful now that she's
partnered up with Joel she's also
working out the math about the value of
her own life versus the value of a
potential cure which is a heck of an
existential crisis for a teenager in the
apocalypse to have on their shoulders
Joel and Ellie don't find the hospital
the hospital finds them or at least the
fireflies who operate it do after a stun
grenade catches them off guard Ellie is
taken to a reclaimed children's surgery
Wing after Joel is knocked out cold with
the butt of a rifle when he comes to
Marlene is there to explain everything
the circumstances of Ellie's birth means
that her body releases chemical signals
that tell cordaccept she's already
infected much like a vaccine a doctor
affiliated with the fireflies thinks he
can reproduce that effect with Ellie's
cells a devastated Joel figures out that
those cells will have to be harvested
from her brain Marlene acknowledges that
she won't survive the surgery but she
tries to comfort Joel by assuring him
that Ellie will die peacefully and
unaware that she won't wake up for the
medication she's been given
that mirrors the game Joel fights like a
demon to rescue Ellie whom he swore to
protect though his main motivation is
surely to save the girl he's come to
think of as a second daughter he objects
to the fact that Ellie wasn't given a
choice in the matter that's his
rationale when he's later confronted by
Marlene in the parking garage since
Ellie wasn't told about the procedure
and since she didn't explicitly tell
Joel she was willing to give her life
for a possible cure there are after all
no guarantees for surgery or
experimental treatments would work he
can't let the fireflies go through their
plan for almost all of season one of The
Last of Us Joel and Ellie are keeping
secrets from each other she lets him and
test in on her big secrets her immunity
pretty quickly but most of their
emotional baggage stays closed up until
the finale that's when Joe reveals the
truth about Sarah and his gunshot wound
and that's when Ellie finally tells Joe
the real story about Riley and the first
time she had to kill eventually Joel
even goes a step further and begins to
openly discuss Sarah again in a way that
he hasn't been able to bring himself to
do since she died Eddie wonders aloud if
what he means is that the passage of
time enabled him to better cope with the
loss of Sarah which means Ellie May
someday be able to better cope with the
loss of Riley so Time Heals all wounds I
guess
it wasn't time that did it it seems like
Ellie and Joel both know they might not
see each other again on the other side
of the Firefly Hospital Mission
throughout the series Ellie and Joel
make references to a scar on the right
side of his head and to the fact that
his hearing is diminished in his right
ear the first version of the story he
tells Ellie is simply that someone shot
at him and missed the audience knows
Joel has been through 20 harsh years
following the courty steps outbreak and
the death of his daughter Sarah so the
fact that he's worse for wear isn't
surprising or particularly noteworthy
viewers may have guessed that the wound
as a result of an early shootout with
authorities or an altercation with
Raiders or other Smugglers at some point
in between 2003 and the present however
in a slight departure from the game Joe
reveals to Ellie that he's the one who
shot and missed the game merely hints
that he's suicidal following Sarah's
death This Moment of extreme honesty and
vulnerability on Joe's Parts comes as he
and Ellie sneak through a long defunct
military medical incumbent Joel
remembers how he flinched at the last
second trying to shoot himself the day
after Sarah died the memory serves to
inform us about Joel's despair on day
two of the outbreak as well as showing
us how quickly civilized Nation fell
apart the other mystery surrounding Ali
have to do with her friend Riley and the
extent to which Ellie is killed before
in episode 1 Marlene mentions someone
named Riley and it strikes a nerve with
Ellie which as the audience's first clue
that something went awry just prior to
the series main storyline early on in
their Journey Ellie confies in Joel that
she has had to defend herself with
violence before to that point viewers
had only seen her put an infected
trapped in a basement out of its misery
so when did Ellie have to kill to defend
herself the answer is revealed in
episode 7 though luckily we don't have
to watch the horrific incident play out
on screen Riley was Ellie's best friend
and secret love interest at the federal
school when Riley was assigned sewage
detail as a federal designated
post-graduate career path she defected
to the fireflies before she shipped out
on duty to another qz Riley plans a best
night of their lives at the mall where
the two experience some rare moments of
Liberty and share their true feelings
for each other you're my best friend
[Music]
and I'll miss you
Riley intends to say goodbye but Ellie
who's less hostile to Federer and unsure
of how to feel about the fireflies asks
her to stay best late plans ready
workout in The Last of Us and Ellie and
Riley are both bitten fighting off
infected in the Halloween store they
decide to live out their final moments
together but as Ellie later accounts to
Joel this is when she discovers that
she's immune Riley succumbs but Ellie
doesn't leaving Ellie no choice but to
kill her crush and best friend season
one of The Last of Us ends on a note
that's both heartwarming and unsettling
Joel and Ellie look out over the
pristine Wyoming landscape about to head
off into an uncertain but somewhat's
hopeful future together then she asks
him to swear that everything he said
about the fireflies was true though Joel
and Ellie have been hiking for hours
only moments ago viewers witnessed what
really happened the fireflies fully
intended to sacrifice Ellie the only
known person with immunity in order to
work toward a possible cure they
attempted to escort Joel out but Joel
fought back systematically gunning down
Firefly after fire life until he reached
Ellie unconscious on a hospital bed and
Marlene tried to convince him to hand
her over he shot her with a gun hidden
under Ellie's limp body of course that's
not the story he tells a confused Ellie
still in her hospital gown Joel explains
that there were dozens like her and that
the fireflies were merely doing some
tests to determine if a cure could be
produced when their immunity couldn't be
replicated they gave up on their
research then according to Joel Raiders
swarmed the building and he just barely
got her out he admits that people died
including Marlene Joel swears that his
fabricated version is true because his
new personal mission is protecting Ellie
at all costs Ellie's response ends a
season just like it ended the game the
finale started with Anna lying to
Marlene and ends with Joel lying to
Ellie
okay
is Ellie saying okay her believing the
LIE accepting the lie or something else
it's open to interpretation but fans of
The Last of Us Part 2 know that their
relationship is forever changed
co-creator Craig Mason in an episode of
the official The Last of Us podcast said
the ambiguity of the ending is the quote
correct way to end the story which is
why he kept it intact from the game it
can be any of those things absolutely
but that's why I love it so what's ahead
for season two Mason and showrunner Neil
druckman aren't saying much but they did
reveal on the podcast that fans can
expect season 2 to have a similar feel
druckman said you could expect us to
repeat the same process the moment to
moment beats and characters they might
stay the same they might change we will
do what needs to happen to that story as
it transfers from one medium to another
and Mason hinted that season 1's
expansion into storylines not found in
the game like the episode 3 tier jerker
will continue Mason said he will also
take advantage of the freedom we have in
television that wasn't there in the game
specifically the advantage of changing
perspective
[Music]